der wald rambo ist mittlerweile einer
der meistgesuchten männer deutschlands
und trotzdem scheint er wie vom erdboden
verschluckt zu sein
die intensiven fahndungsmaßnahmen der
polizei mit spezialkräften mit
mantrailer hunden mit hubschraubern
die lassen allerdings doch darauf
schließen dass die einsatzkräfte davon
ausgehen dass er sich immer noch hier im
wald um oppenau aufhält mittlerweile
wird die einsatzleitung dabei auch von
förstern beraten und bei mir steht jetzt
hubert fischer der ist mehr als 40 jahre
war hier in diesem wald gewesen keiner
kennt ihn weit so gut wie er
herr fischer können sie uns einmal
erklären was ist das hier für ein gebiet
und was macht die suche nach wie vor
schwierig wir sind hier in der region
mittlerer schwarzwald die originale des
gehört zu dieser region und waldbilder
die prägen auch diese landschaft wir
haben ja einen hohen bewaldung sun teil
von 80 prozent das möchte man
verinnerlichen ich eine riesengroße
fläche und der wahrlich geprägt von
verschiedenen wald bildern junge bäume
bis hin zu 150 jährigen fichten und
tannen und buchen die prägen unser bild
und unterstellt sind an dieser alten
häuser von naturverjüngung in der sich
der wald selbst verdient hat und den
wald zu einem gewissen dicht schluss
dabei führt die frau wird sich wohl in
solchen bewegt sich in solchen gebieten
ja bei uns und nutzt natürlich auch
diese gelegenheit sich da weiter zu
entwickeln
wir haben gestern gesehen dass einige
einsatzkräfte von oben bis unten voller
dreck gewesen sind die haben natürlich
auch ihre schwierigkeiten in diesem
gebiet sich zu bewegen was macht denn
die arbeit für diese spezialkräfte so
gefährlich seit sonntag montag haben wir
schönes sommerwetter 14 die letzten zwei
tage da waren sitzt mit regen vernetzt
macht den steilhang mit bis zu 60 70
prozent gefälle sehr schwierig zu
begehen menschen darin auch
weiterzukommen
wie schnell sich die bestände sind nass
die bäume sind nass und ist natürlich
eine gewisse gefährlichkeit auch
vorhanden
was denken sie denn wie lange kann sich
frauchen auch hier verstecken
die frau ist der ort sein an dem man
erkennt die gegebenheiten erkennt die
flächen erkennt und er hat sich diesen
wohl verschrieben jetzt sind den
vergangenen der vergangenen zeit ja auch
im wald sei ein unterstand zu finden
vielleicht auch etwas länger zu leben
gut vielen dank für diese interessanten
infos
wir hoffen natürlich alle dass die
besucher bald ein ende hat wir haben
auch mal eben den hubschrauber wieder
gehört wieder aufgestiegen ist und gehen
wir zurück nach berlin